K's prime minister shik Muhammad bin
abdurahman Alani is in the US he's been
meeting Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin in Washington DC the meeting
comes just a day after he's met
intelligence officials from Egypt Israel
and the US in Paris to discuss a
possible deal to release the captives
held in Gaza he's been going to be
speaking at an event hosted by the
Atlantic Council Think Tank on Regional
deescalation Gaza and the US he's just
had an introduction from Frederick kimp
the president and CEO of the Atlantic
Council let's listen we all agreed to
this weekend to release the hostages in
agreement with uh a phased pause in the
fighting Women and Children First and to
continue this in phases as you proceed
with Aid going in as well uh this is
being presented as we understand it now
to Hamas in the past they have insisted
on an immediate permanent ceasefire
before any hostages can be released
do you think there's a chance that they
might agree to this or would their veto
be a deal
breaker well first of all I would like
to thank you for giving me this
opportunity to speak here today at the
Atlantic Council and I'm honored to be
with both of you Andrea and
David
uh well actually I think that right now
I will describe it the progress uh that
we are ACH that we are making uh in the
last couple of weeks is is we are in
much better place than where we were uh
few weeks ago we have seen that the
whole process was working in November
that resulted in the release of 109
hostages and
unfortunately this process Fallen apart
at that time and the intensity of the
war actually increased that made the
situation more uh complex as you have
highlighted that there was a clear
demand of the permanent ceasefire ahead
of the negotiations which I believe that
uh we moved from that place to a place
where it has potentially might lead to a
ceasefire uh permanently in the future
and this is what we are all aiming for
because we've seen also the suffering of
the people in Gaza and we've seen the
amount of Destruction over there now our
uh main role as a mediator is trying our
best in to get a negotiated solution
where it can brings the hostages safely
back to their homes yet also stopping
the bombing uh Ina and the continuation
of of the killing of the civilians we've
seen the numbers are increasing
dramatically and uh I I mean uh what I
think that uh we are seeing in Gaza is
not resulting with is not getting any
result to get the hostages back but the
process is the one which is getting them
back now on what you have L Andrea I
don't know where did you get all these
details on on the proposals and the
framework but I can say you are well
informed uh we have uh I think yesterday
was good progress made uh to get uh
things back in shape and to at least to
lay a foundation for The Way Forward uh
we cannot say that this uh will makes us
you know uh in better shape very soon
but we are hoping actually uh uh to
relay this proposal to Hamas and to get
them to a place where they engage
positively and constructively in the
process because we think that in
in in today's world I think that's the
only game in town now and that's will be
the only way to get the situation de
escalated and we hope that both parties
taking this opportunity to get of course
uh
uh to make the war stop but also to get
the hostages back to them let me ask you
as a followup whether if the United
States retaliates against
Iran for the attack in Jordan they
killed at least three American soldiers
and dozens more are injured if that were
to happen do you think that that would
Scuttle the
deal well first of all Andrea uh I
express my condolences today to the
secretary in our meeting for the loss of
of the uh three soldiers and we are
hoping that the injured will to
secretary blink to the secretary blink
yeah uh will recover soon and of course
an the attack that happened in Jordan is
condemned infringing Jordan sovereignity
or also undermining the efforts of the
Coalition uh anti Isis is not something
can be acceptable uh What uh uh actually
what we've been warning from is the
bigger picture in the region and we've
been warning from day one that this war
has a potential of expanding and spill
over in the region and we are seeing
this building up unfortunately in the
last three months and a half I hope that
uh nothing would undermine the efforts
that we are doing or jeopardize the
process uh yet it will definitely have
an impact on it and will uh uh one way
or another it will have an impact on on
the regional security and we hope that
uh things get contained and not to get
escalated beyond control shik Muhammad
you said earlier in answer to Andrea's
question that you're waiting for an
answer from Hamas to this question of
whether they're willing to accept a
prolonged pause in fighting but not a
permanent end of the war which Israel is
I understand it is not ready to offer
what if Hamas says
no what's Plan B here because the
situation as you know better than anyone
on the ground in Gaza is horrific well I
think that uh look David first of all uh
putting an end for this War now it's
becoming not only a demand of of the
people in Gaz it's a regional demand and
it's getting Beyond this we have seen
the amount of Destruction that happened
we have seen the number of victims uh we
cannot punish an entire population for
an act of of of small group now what uh
what would be the plan as as an
alternative uh for this deal we have to
seek for another way for for or another
mean to get to a breakthrough where we
can uh get a deal together uh we cannot
uh we are an intermediary party here we
are not party of of this conflict and we
are trying our best to bridge the gap is
the framework that yesterday been agreed
upon with with all the parties was a
framework based on what's been proposed
by the Israelis and what's been a
counter proposal from Hamas and we try
to blend things together to come up with
some sort of a reasonable ground that
brings everybody together
now we don't know and we cannot predict
uh uh what Hamas respond will be and we
we are sure that we will be faced with
some challenges and obstacles but uh and
it's not an easy process since we
embarked it from day one in the war but
we are committed uh uh to continue to
carry forward and to come up with some
solutions that provide
for to Mo if they say no are you
prepared to pressure them you have a lot
of Leverage on Hamas well David this is
actually this point that you have raised
I've been hearing this uh a lot about
the leverage and the pressure uh
the role needs to be understand clearly
in this context our role is is a
mediator we try to bring the parties to
bridge the gaps between them pressuring
them pressuring both of them
by by wordss by by meetings by
commitment by addressing the issues with
with some solutions that's that's the
pressure and The
Leverage Beyond this uh leverage are we
don't see that qar is a superpower that
can impose something on this party or
the other party to bring them uh to that
place basically we are using our good
offices to
uh connect to to bridge gaps to uh put
solutions to come up with some
Alternatives that's uh what qar has as
as an ability and this way has worked
has worked uh previously in in the
process in Gaza has worked in process
between us and Iran has worked in a
process between us and Taliban and it's
been working between Ukraine and Russia
with the Ukrainian children so that's
that's the way that qar is is
operating shik Muhammad Israel has today
released evidence uh supporting its
claim that at least 12 employees of the
UN relief agency
onra had participated or supported the
October 7th Massacre and the evidence is
compelling enough that the UN fired them
the United States and other countries
have cut off funding temporarily while
it's being investigated doesn't this
valid Val Israel's claims against the
un uh which secretary blink had said is
the only game in town for getting Aid in
and you know the implications are that
there'll be more reluctance to get the
aid in which is so critical for the
gazin for the Palestinians there the
civilians and critical to the hostage
deal well actually the role of the UN is
is very important in in that front the
role of Ona itself and we've been seeing
the suffering that they
uh been facing with the cut of funding
uh that's happened to them not now only
but even the short the shortage in
funding that happened to them in the
last few years uh uh it's the only
agency that can provide help and aid for
the Palestinians Ina and the West Bank
now if there are claims uh against some
of the stuff uh there are as I recall
around 12 stuff who been involved in
this these claims needs to be
investigated H needs to take their
measures according to their Charter but
it cannot be punished because of the act
of some employees as long as they are
complying with their including
kidnapping a woman according to the
allegation well no actually none of the
first of all we don't know about uh the
allegation yet until the investigation
come out
yet it's an a behavior of individual or
a group smaller group of people among
tens of thousands who are working in
anad cannot be like a way to label the
entire agency
as violating or adopting uh such act we
believe in the importance of the UN we
believe in the importance of Ona as an
agency and we believe also we have a
confidence that they will follow uh uh
what's what's their rules are are
uh are having them to to follow I mean
it's uh as they mentioned they are
taking all the measures they are
investigating and they fired them this
morning so this is this is at least you
know they are doing their part as an
agency but it cannot be a labeling for
the entire agency finally did Israel
agree as part of the agreement this
weekend in Paris did Israel agree to
accelerate the a deliveries which would
be through the UN well actually uh uh
look unfortunately and this is something
that we've been repeatingly saying
that's you
know it's not a way to use the
humanitarian Aid as as a leverage or as
as as a pressure on the people people in
Gaza are dying from starvation we've
seen the suffering that they are going
through is something unprecedented we we
never seen before in any conflicts and
just let us you know picture
Gaza is the only conflict Zone where the
people have nowhere to go to have no
shelters and even with the safe zones
that they've been allocating and
dedicating for them since the start of
the conflict they've been bombed in the
s in in in those safe corridors in those
safe zones and there are no place safe
for them over there so uh this shouldn't
be part of any deal yet unfortunately
it's being used as a bargaining chip all
the time
shik Muhammad as you said at the outset
we're on the edge of a much wider war
that could involve the United States uh
Iran proxies maybe even Iran so I want
to ask you two questions first after
this attack that killed the three
Americans uh in Northern
Jordan is cutter prepared to condemn
that attack as something that is wrong
well actually that's I just uh mentioned
that very clearly we condemn uh uh any
act that try to first of all uh to
undermine the security and the stability
of the region infringing the security of
a country like Jordan or even uh killing
soldiers who are part of a coalition
that we are a member in so it's not
something can be acceptable yet uh we
are saying that in order to get and to
rescue the region from being going you
know through like more and more
suffering through uh more escalation is
really to find a solution and to put
down what's happening in that's that's a
key thing so you've favored at every
stage uh
mediation uh diplomacy and the
escalation I want to ask you if you are
playing any mediating role now with the
houthis
and what messages your government is
sending to Iran with which you have good
relations well actually there is no any
mediation Ro role that we are playing
with the hthis right now but we are in
continuous conversation with Iran uh
about the regional situation and the
regional escalation we are in
continuous conversation with other what
you say from the region that we would
like uh them to use their links and
their relation with everyone with all
the forces to deescalate and not to uh
get the situation out of control as you
just mentioned uh uh about the houthis
what's happening disrupting the trade
the international trade in the Red Sea
is something affecting all of us freedom
of navigation is something very
important for my country for the entire
region for the world and something
unacceptable to uh uh to be messed up
with yet uh we are seeing that the
situation is is boiling up here and
there and everyone unfortunately is
dancing at the edge uh and we have seen
what happened yesterday uh with the
attack on on and killing the Americans
is is a result of being trying to uh uh
do some operations here and there to
undermine the regional security or to
show that some pressure yet it resulted
with a killing of three
soldiers in leaked audio on Israel
Channel 12 uh prime minister Netanyahu
can be heard criticizing your country
criticizing cter he says I don't thank
hter for the previous hostage releases
why because for me hter is essentially
no different from the UN it is
essentially no different from the Red
Cross and in a way it's even more
problematic does that make it harder for
you to deal with Israel as you were
dealing with Israel this weekend in
Paris well uh honestly Andrea I don't
want to uh comment on on such a
statements and we are not expecting
thanks from from him or from anyone our
we understand our role our role we
believe it's important uh we've been
very honest uh from the beginning we've
been very transparent with everyone and
our role has proven uh uh that it's it's
getting results and not just putting out
some uh some statements or using it for
iCal
exploitation uh and being like similar
to the UN or to the Red Cross those are
humanitarian organization so we are
proud to be among this
club the Su prime minister has also said
that he's against a Palestinian State
and that his goal is to eliminate Hamas
its leadership and its Fighters as part
of this military
campaign do you think that that is
possible without jeopardizing the lives
of the hostages
well uh first of all
uh the only way forward for us to have a
peaceful region is a two-state solution
that's what stood for that's what we are
believing in that's what we believe that
the entire region has adopted long time
ago and the two- State solution uh uh
will of course needs like Partners on on
the other side if we see a leader on uh
the Israeli side who is opposing such a
solution then what's the alternative he
would ask you how can we live side by
side with people who are dedicated to
our
elimination so can there be a two State
solution as long as Hamas is in Gaza
well it's
not where Hamas the obstacles of two
State solution back in after Oso and we
didn't see anything implemented from
there uh in 2001 when Arab peace
initiative was presented did Israel
agree to at least engage in in the
process at that time
with or the Israeli government I think
that it's not uh opposing the two-state
solution and just it's not something new
that happened post of 7th of October it
happened even it was happening before
that for decades so uh for us as Arab
countries as
my country we are country which believes
in peace we support uh uh the
Palestinian cause we support two people
living side by side peacefully together
when we have seen hope in uh in the '90s
after Madrid and also qar was was the
first country in the Gulf that stepped
up and opened an office uh trade office
with Israel and we had a diplomatic
relation at that time uh or a trade
relation at that time time yet we have
seen that the other party or the partner
for peace wasn't serious about it and
that's that's when decided just to close
down this Channel and just keep the
ongoing working Channel but getting back
to Hamas Hamas is dedicated to
eliminating Israel so doesn't Hamas have
to be out of Gaza before there can be
peaceful coexistence well uh
look I I want you know uh
the this dedication of eliminating
Israel we know that
now the only way forward is two State
solution is people living side by side
next to each other now whoever is
accepting this
principle uh uh I believe this is should
be uh you know uh we should deal with
them in in a very positive manner who
but the ones who are not accepting such
a principle what is the alternative that
we are providing for the people who are
willing to accept this principle that's
that's the key
issue uh your EXC Excellency I want to
ask two questions about what we describe
as the day after the day after this
terrible war ends and what governance
would look like the first is whether you
imagine that Hamas would play a role
in the governance of Gaza and of an
eventual Palestinian State Israel would
strongly oppose that what would gutter's
position be well our position that the
fate of the Palestinians should remain
at the hands of the Palestinians they
are the ones who should decide what will
be the way forward for us we see that
the way forward that Gaza cannot be
addressed separately or an isolation
from the West Bank uh and there should
be one government that take care of Gaza
and the West Bank together we have uh uh
the Palestinian Authority uh whatever
their reforms uh they are willing to do
but yet this is a decision of the
Palestinians the Palestinians factions
those are the ones who can decide who
should govern them or should not neither
qar nor Israel nor anyone I believe in
the position to impose on them uh uh
something else or what we believe is
right for them and I I I take it from
your earlier comments in answer to
Andrea that you think Hamas should
accept Israel's right to exist as the
price of being part of the future is
that a fair statement well I think that
the statement that I'm saying that
everyone uh now I I'll just take a step
back uh whether it's Hamas fat or any
political ideology or political party
it's uh uh there this ideology is is an
idea for you uh to challenge this idea
is to present a better idea and the
better idea here is the two-state
solution and now whoever is opposing the
two-state solution if the majority is
agreeing to I I think the people
themselves will will have the answer to
that so that's why I'm saying that we
are not in position to decide on of the
Palestinian people uh they have uh they
can decide on their own and we believe
that the only way forward that's been
embraced and you know adopted by
everybody including uh the Palestinian
Authority is to have the Palestinian
State uh living side by side uh to
Israel quick final question uh Prim
Minister Netanyahu but many others
including many US officials have said
that a future Palestinian States should
be effectively
demilitarized able to take care of
security but not able to launch Wars
against its neighbors do you agree with
that well we don't want to see any
country able to launch a war against its
neighbor and we want to live you know
peacefully uh with each other
specifically what about I I think that
the any peace plan should includes
enough security guarantees for both
people that they don't represent threats
to each other we've been told credibly
that u i mean there's documentary
evidence of the way the women were
treated women who were dead who were
killed on October 7th women hostages as
well um the
rape the sex is being used as a weapon
of
war and that there have been abuses
continuing what in their
captivity so there's such a priority on
releasing these women who should have
been released back in November when that
was the
agreement um what hope can you present
to the hostage families you met with
them in Doha you've you've reached out
to them your
country uh some of them are here in the
audience what message can you give to
the hostage families of getting their
children their relatives home well of
course uh uh these kind of Acts
are unacceptable and are condemned and
this is something that uh no faith uh no
human being can can accept and
we uh
regarding our role uh in trying our best
to get those hostages free this is
something that we've been doing from day
one even without being asked uh when we
have seen uh this situation erupted we
reached out uh to Hamas right away and
we were demanding to release all the
hostages unfortunately things went to
another Direction and didn't work out uh
the way everyone wanted at the beginning
yet uh we have uh uh been very
persistent and committed to the process
that led uh to the first release we are
hoping for this process to uh you know
to to continue uh to produce for us uh
some good results and and release the
rest of them and uh what my message
always to them that uh to them and to
the Palestinian people that we are
committed to put down this conflict to
release the
hostages uh His Highness the Amir has
been repeatingly uh very
uh persistent on making sure that all of
us we are working toward that direction
uh when whenever we are hearing
disturbance and noises here and there he
always says we shouldn't care about
these you know uh uh negative things as
long as it's going to result with saving
a single life that will be worth it for
us and that's what stood for from the
beginning and will continue standing for
you've been uh living with this crisis
uh since soon after October 7 as a
mediator uh following it uh dayto day
with Israeli mosad officials CI director
Burns and others I want to ask you
somebody who's so close to it the
question that was put to General
Petraeus at the beginning of the Iraq
War which is tell tell me how this ends
in your mind as a mediator what does the
Middle East look like in five years if
you're successful in your
mediation well it depends to what
direction this mediation will if we
will get to a situation where the war is
ended and we go back to the same uh
previous status which is separate Gaza
and the West Bank no hope uh for a
political resolution and uh the region
uh remains as a hostage of of you know
some political Dynamics happening here
or there then we are going to be in much
worse situation 5 years from now and the
situation will not uh uh the attack that
happened in 7th of October there is
another one there is a bigger war will
happen and uh honestly uh we don't see
like a positive perspective out of it
but if we are going to seize this
opportunity we are going to ensure that
after this there is an an international
commitment for a peaceful resolution for
a two-state Solutions there is a PA
clear path for the Palestinians for
their
statehood then it will be much better uh
picture for all of us and much better
perspective uh in the region and we are
hoping to choose this path not to go
with the previous path do you think Iran
would agree with that it's Iran's
proxies the hoodis heah amas well
[Music]
it's look I I don't want to
uh speak on behalf of any country yet uh
I'm telling you that my position as
state of B uh our position there in the
state of our position in the region that
we are agreeing for this as long as the
region uh and the parties are agreeing
to this that will be the best guarantor
for for the future process we have
questions now David and I are receiving
from the audience both here and
virtually
um from Thomas War Hamas put out a
statement in English two weeks ago
justifying its October 7th attack
notably it called for a Palestinian
state but failed to call for a two-state
solution will you publicly call for
Hamas to publicly accept a two-state
solution well actually our call for the
pal for the entire Palestinian people is
to accept a two-state solution that's uh
that's our position and that's what we
see the only way forward for us so I'm
looking at the next question uh Mr Prime
Minister you've repeatedly said that
cutter is a neutral mediator which has
no leverage over the parties other than
words yet it's been widely reported that
for years the top leadership of Hamas
has lived in Cutter how does that square
with your claim of being a neutral
mediator do you really have no leverage
over over an organization whose top
leaders live in your country and that
comes from Professor or kry well uh I
think that this uh uh Living in Qatar
has been always like taking out of
context uh Qatar has uh Hamas political
office now for almost 11 years it
happened with in full coordination with
the United States to establish
communication channels and to be used in
uh resolving the situation in the region
it has managed multiple deescalation
Seas far ERS throughout uh the years and
it's proven to be effective we hosted
Taliban political office that resulted
uh uh to the agreement between us and
Taliban and it doesn't mean that uh
being there hosting them is is is a is a
leverage that that we have over them and
qar role has been very clear very
transparent dealt with in uh uh very
close coordination whether it's with the
us or with the other uh uh parties that
related to any conflict so I we don't
see that this is uh as a point of
Leverage we see this as a point as a
Channel of communication that we are
using always for good causes and a brief
followup I want to ask you whether the
Israeli mosad their intelligence service
with which you've dealt for now for some
years has been a a reliable negotiating
partner
well actually the negotiation that we
have uh like accomplished whether it's
on uh this conflict or with on the
previous conflicts it was always
happening through them and uh we have
seen the results actually that's that's
the best judge for it we have a question
that has been submitted anonymously I
want to read it though because uh the
question is about the collapsing
situation in Sudan with the K role to
end the crisis over there especially um
what what is the excuse me KH role to
end the crisis over there especially
with kter success before in darur peace
talks and the ability of KH to group the
Sudanese parties I asked this uh just
coincidentally I was there with our un
Ambassador on the Chad side of the
border at uh questioning refugees and um
the toll on the civilian population in
darur as it was when I was there in 200
5 with the Secretary of State at the
time con Lisa Rice it is horrific and um
largely ignored by the world but does KH
have a role well to see what's happening
in in in Sudan is heartbreaking for all
of us and we've seen the suffering that
the Sudanese people has been going
through now for for the last year but
it's even going beyond that uh qar right
now specifically we are not playing
playing any specific role in in in
what's happening in Sudan yet there is a
process in place with uh with Saudi and
we are very supportive for the process
in order to get them uh uh to an
agreement between the fighting parties
and to transit to uh like more permanent
status for the government of Sudan and
to put down this Forest as
possible I want to ask a question of my
own and then turn to one from uh our
audience uh I've often visited alade uh
air base in gutter which is one of the
largest US military bases
overseas um you're a mediator uh between
the US and and various uh forces like
Hamas and and others uh talk a little
bit about your alliance with the United
States and the bet that you're making on
the United States by having that huge
base there well actually I believe that
the relationship with the US has been
always strong I mean this is an alliance
that we built decades ago uh between the
two countries and uh it's not only on
defense security and Regional security
it's going beyond that it's on there are
strong economic partnership between the
two countries uh huge investment
presence for state of qar uh in the
United States and huge investment by
American companies in qar and the energy
sector of course is is a partnership
that we are uh proud of and uh American
companies are working together very
closely with us in the area of Education
with six American universities uh being
in qar uh and serving as a hub for the
region uh to be provided with the US
education within the region so uh this
relationship has been always very stable
very strong very institutional and
that's what safeguarded the relationship
of course when we see that uh uh we are
helpful and we can provide uh uh support
for the US in different conflicts we
always uh of course look at this as as
an opportunity just to strengthening the
bonds between our two countries and I
believe that this is something good for
qar to have reliable Partners such as
United States but also good for United
States have a reliable partner like said
f let me just paraphrase this question
from Yad shamal how can the existing
diplomatic and mediation be stepped up
to get us from where we are which is
conflict worsening conflict to peace and
stability do we need an International
Conference do we need a greater role for
the UN what what more can be done to
bring this
home well I think that uh there is an
ongoing uh Regional efforts right now
together with some International
Partners in order to see what's the way
forward uh
uh I think that all of us we are uh very
much calibrated toward how
to seize the opportunity right now and
to put everything on track and to go uh
toward a two uh a two State solution and
the peaceful resolution in the entire
region just let us picture this if we
can put an end for this conflict that's
been lasting for decade the entire face
of the region will change and anyone uh
who will claim the opposite the people
of the region are the ones who are stand
going to stand against it let me also
add one of mine uh we talked earlier
about your concerns about an escalation
at this point given what happened in
Jordan and now the pledge from the
president of the United States to
retaliate um he's being pressured by
Senator Graham and other critics to go
directly to Iran to retaliate inside
Iran if he were to do that since
deterrence clearly has not worked there
have been 160 attacks uh would he be
justified what would be the impact if
the US strikes inside
Iran well actually we don't encourage
any attacks to happen in any country in
in our region and we believe the ones
who are responsible for the attacks
those are the ones who uh should be held
accountable of course we are calling for
deescalation to contain the situation as
much as possible and we are hoping that
this doesn't go and doesn't reach to
that level our region cannot uh uh just
live with more escalation and further
escalation and we have to focus on the
main issue over there getting things
back and restoring Caz is going to be
key to diffuse all other escalations in
the region but do you think what these
militias have done and there's some
evidence that may have come from Syria
from Iranian back militias there what
they and what the hoodies have done with
the Red Sea could any of that happen
without Iran arming them or does it even
go beyond that directed by the regime
well I look I will go back to the
parties who are carrying on these
conducts those are the ones who need to
be held accountable for any misconduct
or any attempt to undermine the peace
and
security uh in the region we are not in
position to point uh fingers on this or
that uh right now and I believe that for
us the key focus should be how we
contain the situation how we deescalate
it how to uh uh to address the real
issue and not just to treat the
symptoms final question as we get near
the end of of our a lot of time in the
past there's been a lot of tension
between your country cutter and the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia next door to you
how are relations today and where do you
think they're heading well I think we
are we are in a very good shape uh uh
look Saudi qar qar GCC relationship it's
it's not just you know a traditional
relationship it's a historical bond
between all the countries we are
connected families societies are are
very much connected it's uh it's not
something you know uh to go through some
some difficulties from time to time we
understand this we are trying to deal
with it uh in a wise Manner and uh to
overcome it and to look you know for a
better future our relation with Saudi uh
right now is very good very strong we
are working together very closely when
it comes to the conflict now in in in
Gaza as well and also on on a
bilateral uh uh on a bilateral level I
think the collaboration between and
Saudi has been improving a lot in the
past few years and this is what we are
focusing on how to make sure that uh GCC
relationship always protected always
safeguarded and how to build to build an
area of common interest between all of
us in order to avoid any differences in
the
future well thank you so much uh on
behalf of myself NBC News and of course
the Atlantic Council here welcoming us
David so uh shik Muhammed I last talk
with you at Doha uh like all of us I
followed your efforts to mediate uh an
end of this terrible hostage problem and
the larger war with interest and
appreciation thank you so much for
talking with me and Andrea today and
with the audience here well thank you
thank you very much for having
you